que je compare de jennifer aniston et de
brad pitt qui serait à nouveau en forme
c'est selon le magazine britannique now
or là ils se seraient revus
donc il y eu bat python sail est
actuellement en instance de divorce ça
prend du temps avec angie un joli ça se
passe mal et jennifer aniston de son
côté elle est plus avec justin theroux
elle serait donc un coeur à prendre
c'est la façon c'est un peu ça peu
l'arlésienne 1 ça se passe mal à chaque
fois alors est-ce qu'une romance est à
nouveau possible
est ce qu'on peut se remettre avec son
ex est ce que c'est le futur couple ta
réponse ce sera dans un instant après ça
c'était le couple d'hollywood qui vous
faisait rêver vous avez pleuré à chaudes
larmes lorsqu'il se sont séparés il ya
13 ans et bien voici lueur d'espoir brad
pitt et jennifer aniston serait en train
de se rapprocher
c'est la folle rumeur people du moment
basée sur des éléments bond qui valent
ce qu'ils valent d'abord brad et jen
rabibocher ça peut paraître logique lui
était parti avec angelina jolie elle a
eu le coeur très brisé avant de se
réfugier dans les bras de justin theroux
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ils sont tous les
deux divorcés fois de plus doués de plus
tentant alors que de se réfugier auprès
de l'âme soeur pour y trouver du
réconfort
de là à dire que c'est prouvé on en est
encore loin car c'est un tout petit
détail qui a lancé la rumeur il ya cinq
semaines jennifer aniston était en
italie vous n'y croirais pas brad pitt
aussi de quoi faire galoper la presse
people
mais attendez ce n'est pas tout angelina
et justin les deux époux évincé se
fréquenteraient aussi de très près au
mal quand une sorte de chassé croisé ou
bien un double conte de fée pour vous
info ou intox
voilà est-ce qu'une romance est encore
possible info intox les chroniqueurs ont
répondu et chez vous dites nous c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir vos
réponses qu'elles coupent préférez-vous
jennifer aniston et brad pitt ou
angelina jolie et brad pitt
moi j'ai ma réponse j'attends de savoir
la vôtre ça fait une heure qu'elle lève
la main comme ça si c'est pas
intéressant ce que tu vas dire vraiment
catherine info voilà est-ce que vous
c'est une info donc oui c'est une info
j'adore ça et je parie qu'ils vont se
remettre ensemble qui vont même se
remarier près comme liz taylor et
richard burton je parle d'un temps que
les moins de 20 ans peut pas les moins
de 50 ans et je mise là dessus j'adore
cette histoire quand elle dit qu'il l'a
quitté en 2005 elle a été très digne
très malheureuse et je pense que la
séparation avec angelina se passant
tellement mal
ouais ya un vrai petit oui moi ce qui
m'intéresse aussi c'est d'abord des
infos notamment peut-être demi rien de
la presse people
au delà d'un avis est-ce que vous avez
des infos ou est ce qu'ils se revoient
vraiment excuse mais là c'est
complètement faux ils sont pas des fines
n'importe quoi non tout laissait que je
te dois catherine nettement bino ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que notre un peu
comme la chaîne à l'employeur ils
bouffent des choses et c'est pour le
coup ils sont pas du tout ensemble et ça
c'est pas ils sont pas près de se
remettre ensemble de façon définitive
très bien mais bien creux vont un peu ça
coûte ils se sont réconciliés parce que
george clooney les un peu rabibocher il
était très fâché de graco hors de
question qu'ils voient là il parlait
plus du tout mais on n'est plus très
loin d'une heure c'est vraiment il a
suivi pendant dix ans je crois quasiment
pour les paparazzis et c'était vous avez
suivi 'range' à jolie et brad pitt c'est
sébastien c'est vrai ça ben je les ai
suivis depuis le tout début de leur
couple jusqu'à la fin et dans le monde
entier
vraiment j'étais derrière eux soit aux
états unis en thaïlande à prague à
venise
j'ai toujours en live mais bien et
preuves à force oui il me connaissait et
puis bon ça les faisait marrer en voyant
un jour à venise
un mois après en thaïlande et il est
encore là au bout d'un moment on rigole
et mais il faut savoir que il y avait
une jalousie maladive d'angelina jolie
par rapport à jennifer aniston donc brad
pitt n'a pas du tout vu jennifer aniston
pendant toute cette période et
d'après mes petits copains qui font le
même métier que moi à los angeles n'y a
rien du tout entre eux c'est juste
qu'ils se sont peut-être retrouver voilà
c'est ouais ça a été monté de toutes
pièces diouf dia eu un dîner il ya eu un
ou de dîner ensemble du dîner ensemble à
wigan après deux journées ensemble cette
semaine on sait pas sauté dans la rue
non plus commandes des textes dieu
préserve encore catherine voilà qu'en
savez vous moi ce que je veux dire c'est
moi c'est nous pas parler de moi mais
c'est quand même mais moi comme par
hasard chez un petit peu seul et tout
d'un coup je rends un petit texto
annexes avec général voilà ça veut quand
même dire bon est ce que tu es libre et
aux hauts aux murs entre voix aux
personnes qui planquent une énorme
bataille daniel la grand mère appelait
ça un petit coup de revenez-y c'est vrai
donc moi j'y crois à fond
je n'ai visé au non respect des
midinettes et ya quand même des petites
choses c'est que jennifer aniston
normalement préparerait un livre
justement sur sa réconciliation avec
brad donc quand même vous à dire oui et
puis la famille de brad pitt a toujours
beaucoup aimé jennifer aniston et on
peut être conseillé j'aime bien faire
des accolades à bellmer attend que le
petit lucas pas parlé non mais à chaque
fois que jennifer aniston est
célibataire et c'est très régulier parce
qu'elle se fait larguer tous les 2-3 ans
et à chaque fois on remet brad pitt
jennifer aniston ans son père a eu parce
que ce coupé t mythique les gens en ont
envie des couvertures comme ça avec des
ânes sont brad pitt y en a plus de 50
quoi de ma vie depuis les 13 ans qui
sont séparés et ce qui est sûr et
certain c'est qu'elle va jamais retourné
avec lui sachant qu'elles avaient été
humiliés d'une manière elle est passée
comme pour la looseuse vraiment et non
parce que c'est pas comme nous quand on
se fait larguer connu qui le savons elle
quand elle se fait larguer tout le monde
là dessus elle est passée pour la loose
et de la peau fille qu'on aura jamais
d'enfant que machin elle a dû remonter
ça pendant treize ans après il faut
mettre avec moi ce que je vois c'est
qu'à 50 ans tous les deux ans il se fait
larguer d'un peu commode m'a manqué
c'est lui n'est pas célibataire
en tout cas on n'est pas célibataire lui
lui il a des petites copines en ce
moment qui sont pas connus il fait très
attention mais il est pas célibataire
guénange financement non mais sylvie il
ya aux états unis n'ont cédé nana qui
sont pas connus justement à régler
et d'ailleurs il préfère être avec des
filles comme ça pas connu et il a
beaucoup moins dans merde donc en ce
moment c'est ce qu'il fait et c'est ce
qu'ils comptent faire bon jeu pareil je
veux dire c'est pas d'ennuis alors là
vous me voyez vous dois rien à personne
doit rien à personne attend 24 je sais
que vous avez vous aimez bien les
beaucoup mais j'aimerais avoir le
résultat du sondage savoir ce que les
gens préfèrent et ben voilà les gens
aiment bien un petit peu quand même la
nostalgie la roma et puis je peux vous
dire qu'à mon avis elle c'est mon avis
les c'est une méchante ou c'est une
méchante salle à la citadelle est donc
confiant je le sens ça